hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my flash episode 14 video
fallout but they just announced the
schedule is changing so I'll try to
explain that first in the promo for
episode 15 of the flash
they said it's not airing till March
17th that means three weeks with no new
episode the reason they're doing that is
probably to promote the premiere of
iZombie because IB is premiering on
March 17th so they have this bananas
quote-unquote episode of the flash in
order to help boost the numbers for
iZombie yes it sucks but you can't blame
them for wanting to use their most
popular show to promote a new one and
the good news is is arrow episode 15
will air without a break so this week we
have arrow episode 14 then episode 15
nanda parbat airs next week then it also
goes on break so flash and arrow will be
one episode apart for a couple weeks but
they'll sync up again before the finales
so don't worry that's just three more
weeks of the flash tacked on to when we
normally would have ended okay so lots
of big stuff to get through lots of
Easter eggs so let's just start with top
five moments careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet number five
team flash starts to understand the
firestorm matrix the beginning of the
episode picked up immediately after last
week's episode so whenever you're
watching this in the future just watch
them back-to-back and it'll be like a
two-hour episode the first half was all
about introducing firestorm second half
all about understanding what it's gonna
be like going forward so by the end of
the episode they figure it out a little
bit better and they can coexist
inside the firestorm matrix as distinct
personalities that floaty head voice
that you heard from Martin Stein that's
how it is in the comics a lot of the
bickering they did is also from the
firestorm comics to that this part of
the dynamic between Ronnie Raymond and
Martin Stein on to number four iris West
is going to start investigating STAR
Labs they just teased it in the episode
but what I feel like is gonna happen is
iris will learn Barry is the flash by
the end of the season
she'll be investigating STAR Labs
because all these mysterious metahumans
all this crazy stuff going on and as a
consequence of that she'll learn that
Barry's the flash eventually what I'd
like to see is her become the focal
point of the battle between the flash
and the reverse flash and possibly the
creation of a second reverse flash I
know in the promo for episode 15 we saw
Harrison wells used the Speed Force to
split himself in two to make it appear
like there were two of them but I'm
expecting another reverse flash like an
Eddie Thawne reverse flash to be created
by the end of the season
on to number three Harrison wells helps
general Eiling capture Martin Stein I
saw a lot of people were confused about
this on Twitter you know why would
Harrison Wells help general Eiling if he
wants to help team flash and learn more
about firestorm well really it's that
second thing I think he just wanted to
learn more about the nature of fire
storms powers I think he was telling the
truth when he said I don't understand
how firestorm works knowing that he as
the reverse-flash is weak against fire
storms power it's like we learned in
episode 9 he probably wants to learn as
much as he can about him supposedly
firestorm is gonna be back for the
finale it hasn't been confirmed by the
CW I don't know what he's gonna be doing
I'm hoping that the reverse-flash uses
fire storms powers to enact some plot
but he might just come back to help
fight the reverse-flash they wouldn't
bring the character back just to have a
pizza party with team flash so whatever
is happening firestorm is important to
the finale moving on to number two Barry
is going to use his knowledge of the
past to try and save his mother so
they're slowly pushing in the
time-travel I like the way they compared
back to the future rules and terminator
rules really what you need to watch out
for is predestination paradox whereby if
he changes the past if he saves his
mother it might prevent him from ever
becoming the flash and therefore being
able to go back in time and save his
mother if you've seen the animated movie
flashpoint this is what it's all about
Barry goes back saves his mother and it
completely messes up the timeline
everything goes bananas to make another
gorilla grodd joke just feel free to
make any Grodd Bananas jokes you want
throughout this video there was an
earlier episode this season where Joe
tells Barry you need to learn to live
with the things that you can't change so
that's gonna be part of his arc the
season learning that he can't save his
mother no matter how powerful he gets
the same thing is true for the
reverse-flash in the comics the
professor zoom reverse flash he hates
Barry Allen wants to kill him but if he
kills Barry Allen then he'll never
become the reverse flash in the future
so both the flash in the reverse flash
are stuck in this causality loop and my
number 1 moment obviously not God Grodd
the best end credits seen all season
not only does Harrison wells unmask
himself to someone as the reverse flash
we also get to hear Grodd speak and use
his powers of mind control the TV show
is playing a little bit with the origin
stories Harrison well
confirms that he is a metahuman but
technically the flash isn't a metahuman
metahumans as the show defines them were
people that got powers because of the
Dark Matter explosion the flash and the
reverse flash both got their powers from
the Speed Force in the the negative
Speed Force which is not part of the
dark matter in the comics but I think
the show is just combining those things
so technically you could call the flash
of metahuman this doesn't really change
anything that we didn't already know
about Harrison wells other than when he
said I take care of my own it's
interesting to think that he is
protecting the other metahumans whenever
we first got that Gorilla Grodd
flashback it seemed like he cared for
him like he was trying to help him it
humanizes him a little bit but there's a
very nefarious undertone it's like yes
I'm going to protect this gorilla but
only so I can use him to do something
really awful and in the promo for
episode 15 he basically calls Barry
Allen a surrogate son in the comics
professor zoom bar Thawne isn't like
that at all he's completely nuts he
hates everyone so this is the show just
softening that character and using some
aspects from Hunter Zola Monts character
in the comics so what you're getting is
an amalgam of reverse flashes and
eventually when we get a third reverse
flash when we get like our Eddie Thawne
reverse flash I think the same thing
will happen he'll also be in a Malcolm
of a couple reverse flashes one of the
biggest questions you guys had after
last week's episode was when his team
flash gonna learn what Harrison wells is
doing that he's the reverse-flash and
the promo for episode 15 seems like it
totally answers that meaning that
there's like eight episodes left in the
season does that not get you so freakin
excited for where they're gonna take the
show let me know that what was your
favorite moment from the episode and
here's my big question what do you think
that Harrison wells is going to do once
he reveals himself to Barry as the
reverse-flash
it's definitely gonna break their
relationship once Barry learns that he's
the man in yellow
remember what Harrison wells said though
when he was talking about firestorm
except each other except the balance
between you he was talking about Ronnie
Raymond and Martin Stein accepting each
other but really the double meaning is
is the flash needs to learn to accept
the reverse flash Tom Cavanagh amazing
actor was really open during the tcas
earlier this year about how he builds in
double meanings to each of his lines I
know sometimes when he says one thing it
sounds like he might be dropping Easter
eggs for something else it's totally
true he's too
doing that all the time so just remember
that whenever you hear him saying
something that sounds really suspicious
here are some of the really cool Easter
eggs that I found that I haven't already
mentioned yet both Martin Stein and
Ronnie Raymond when they're separated
heat up to about a hundred and six
degree resting temperature issue 106 of
the flash was the debut of Gorilla Grodd
obviously we saw a Gorilla Grodd full-on
at the end of the episode when Barry
goes back into his old house and said
that mirror belonged to my grandmother
iris west-allen obviously she gets
married to barry allen in the comics
they have children their children have
children so iris west-allen becomes the
grandmother of the bart allen flash in
the episode they're using the mirror to
look into the past but it's also an
easter egg for what's going to happen in
the future for the future the flash
lineage when Martin Stein talks about
time-traveling
using a quote-unquote Highway really
that's the speed force the Speed Force
is the highway moving so fast that you
punch a hole in the space-time continuum
we're supposedly gonna get a teaser for
that in episode 15 but I have no idea
what its gonna look like
Caitlin mentioned Jason rush again Jason
rush also becomes part of the firestorm
matrix in the comics it seems like
they're gonna stick with Martin Stein
and Ronnie Raymond with that pairing
through season two
they say that Ronnie is Caitlin's cousin
from coast city that's obviously where
Green Lantern's from I know we all want
to see him on the show at some point
Martin Stein talks to Harrison Wells and
says I should have spent my life trying
to be the best husband I could for my
wife I feel like that was a bit of a
loaded moment because it makes you think
of Harrison wells dead wife which is
probably the reason why he's trying to
gain the powers of the flash so that he
can go back in time and save his wife
it's romantic in a really pathological
way this is a really funny one Ronnie
Raymond itches a message into his arm so
that it appears on Martin Stein's arm
but instead of scratching the answer on
his arm Martin Stein just taps Morse
code
the reason it's funny is because Ronnie
didn't need to cut himself he could have
used Morse code too when Ronnie says
Martin Stein has a friend in Pittsburgh
that can help him it's actually an
easter egg for the comics Ronnie Raymond
in the comics is from Pittsburgh at the
end of the episode general Eiling says
that voice in my head that's just a
reference to gorilla grodd's powers he
has powers of mind control Cisco says I
bet you that's where they're keeping the
aliens too it could have been an Easter
Egg for Martian Manhunter or Superman
from flashpoint if you guys did see any
of
Easter eggs in the episode just right
and below in the comments and the only
real thumbs down I had in the episode
was the iris West storyline I feel like
it's really far behind it's moving way
slower than all the other storylines is
it's lagging behind big time I feel like
something really big is gonna have to
happen in the next three or four
episodes to bring iris West to the
forefront of the story that's probably
gonna be this investigation into STAR
Labs so hopefully that will happen
sooner rather than later Candice Patton
is a great actress but I feel like iris
West character hasn't caught up with the
rest of the show yet since there's no
new episode of the flash next week I'm
just gonna do a bonus video be sure to
subscribe to get it feel free to leave
me any requests you guys want and
remember new episode of arrow tomorrow
and then another new episode of arrow
next week while you guys wait for that
stuff you can click here to get ready
for arrow and you can click here to
watch last week's episode of the flash
thank you so much for watching so let's
all high-five I'll see you guys tomorrow
you